[Music]
you were in a train wreck and you were
hilarious you were great I mean you very
much movie it came out of nowhere but
you were very funny in the park
did you like shooting those scenes in
trainwreck those those love scenes it
was awkward yeah didn't they they wanted
awkward so we gave them awkward yeah
yeah I don't know it got you in a little
bit of trouble with your girlfriend Amy
a little bit of trouble I just [ __ ]
myself okay you gave me a look like
you're gonna tear my head off so
honestly I didn't think I get I didn't
think I get the part yeah and I kept
putting it off not telling Nicole and
not having the discussion of hey there
may be some graphic scenes so I got it
and I couldn't say no so I kind of like
walked in one day and like hey I'm I'm
kind of just doing this yeah and that
was the wrong approach yeah I mean she
has such such beautiful brown eyes and
they glowed with red Hellfire yeah and
like she is such a such a great smile
but she turned into like the alien and
the predator wants it and you didn't ask
from you instead of saying is it okay if
I do this it was more like a forgiveness
thing yeah and note to all you guys out
there that's a bad approach yeah you had
a good look in the movie this is a look
that that I've supported 1 or 2 times
just walking around as I stated before
they wanted awkward su-kam are awkward
all right
you